hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt viel
mehr zuschauer haben sich einmal wieder
ein dessert gewünschte in letzter zeit
gab es auf kuchen und torten und da mal
wieder was herzhaftes aber schon lange
nicht mehr so ein dessert was man
einfach schön auch servieren kann
so nach einem essen und deswegen habe
ich mich für ein paar veh entschieden
denn kaffee kann man super einfach
vorbereiten kaffee kommt aus dem titel
fraglichen halb gefroren ist und ich
habe mich so ein schokoladen café
entschieden mit brownies und mit
cranberries das heißt ihr werdet jetzt
in diesem video sehen wie ich die
brownies herstelle und dann wie das café
hergestellt wird und im prinzip ist noch
gar nicht schwierig ihr müsst nur ein
paar dinge beachten die eier masse ein
bisschen erhalten damit einfach keine in
den eiern abgetötet werden
deswegen startet jetzt gleich mit den
braunen zeige ich dann danach wie die
kaffeemarke hergestellt wird
für die brownies brauche ich 100 gramm
butter 150 gramm tat bitter schokolade
100 gramm zucker 25 milliliter kaffee
oder espresso eine prise salz etwas von
den extrakt 200 gramm mehl 30 gramm
kakaopulver und 100 gramm walze die
braun jetzt in ganz einfach ich nehme
jetzt zuerst einmal die butter den kommt
in einem top-auto die schokolade und
auch der kaffee wobei ich hier espresso
habe weil wir den geschmack sehr gerne
mögen und jetzt stelle ich dein herz auf
mittlerer stufe und lass das ganze jetzt
erwärmen aber nicht heiß werden also
nicht kochen lassen wird es einfach
schokolade und butter schmelzen und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
wahlen ist frei
die schokoladenmasse ist geschmolzen
jetzt kann ich alle zutaten einfach in
einer schüssel verrühren da braucht
jetzt auch gar keine küchenmaschine dazu
es geht alles ganz gut mit dem bug
löffel einfach alles rein extrakt das
hätte ich auch nicht fehlen und die
prise salz die hebt den geschmack und
gleich das ganze auch so ein bisschen
aus
alles nur noch ganz vorsichtig berührt
jetzt ist der frau nie teig fertig und
ich kann ihn jetzt in meine backform
einführen und zwar nämlich sein einen
wachhabenden eckigen wenn ich später in
würfel schneiden
das sind dies ganz gut wenn die form
eckig ist und den habe ich auch eine
parodie und auf meinem gelochten
backblech
die brawnies im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober unterhitze zehn
minuten gebacken
im innern dürfen gerne rechtsstaatlich
und feucht werden die brownies sind
jetzt fertig und die last jetzt hier
kurz abkühlen und werde in der
zwischenzeit schon mal dass kaffee
zubereiten
kaffee ist halb gefroren ist also heißt
und dieses wird ausser und aus eiern und
zucker hergestellt und die eier zucker
masse wird vorher erhitzt das heißt ihr
habt dann auch später keine rohen eiern
mit drin und braucht keine angst haben
dass da keine mit drin sind die werden
nämlich durch die hitze abgetötet falls
überhaupt welche drin sind und ich werde
jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen zeit
bitterschokolade mit reingeben und sag
ich mal die zutaten für das paket
brauche ich 150 bitterschokolade 50
gramm joghurt feier eine prise salz
etwas vanille extra 80 gramm zucker und
500 milliliter schwarzer dem ist zuerst
einmal die schokolade und des lugert
über ein heißes wasserbad
da habe ich das wasser vorher einfach
aufkochen lassen wieder den herd
ausgemacht und die hitze reicht es
vollkommen aus um die schokolade zu
schmelzen
während es hier jetzt passiert werde ich
schon mal die eier zucker massa hier
drüben verrühren und zwar solltet ihr
jetzt weiß jetzt keine kennen kennwort
cooking chef mit hitze funktion habt
dann solltet ihr das ganze auch über dem
heißen wasserbad machen und da darf das
wasserbad kochen
also ich zeige euch das jetzt erst mal
hier und erkläre euch gleichzeitig wie
ihr das dann mit dem wasserbad machen
gibt dafür nämlich die eier in einer
schüssel
da kommt die polizei lange dazu und auch
der zucker und ich stelle die maschine
bei mir auf 80 grad
und die eier zucker master werde ich
jetzt auf stufe 2 bis 3 verrühren und
wechselt dann auf 80 grad erhitzen und
etwa fünf minuten lang die temperatur
halten und es zeige ich euch jetzt hier
mal kurz
als ihr müsst schnell genug dürfen damit
einfach keine ruhe rein steht und über
dem heißen wasser geht es so dass sie
eben auch wieder die hier ein wasserbad
macht das heißt einen topf mit heißem
wasser abstellen und eine schüssel
drüber stellen und das wasserbad soll
dann kochen also ins wasser missbrauchen
damit die eier masse eben 80 grad
erreicht
über der cooking chef ist desto das
zeige sich auch noch gut wenn viele
fragen mich immer warum dies nicht
abschaltet zwar hat die sob schnitt drin
wenn die temperatur von 60 grad nämlich
erreicht ist weil sie
möglichkeit runter einfach damit keine
heißen flüssigkeiten und zukunft
ausschütten können das heißt mehr gleich
diese taste 360 jetzt wird langsamer und
jetzt drückt er der dpa
solange
aufhört
und dann geht die geschwindigkeit
nämlich wieder ruhig einfach hitzeschutz
und sicherheitsschutz und dem sollte die
alte ist
jetzt lasse ich das ganze auf 80 grad
erhitzen und das ganze fünf minuten ein
wer möchte kann jetzt gerne noch zum
kaffee als dieser eier zucker master
etwas likör oder zum beispiel kaffee
zufügen und dafür nehmen wir einfach
drei esslöffel davon und geht es mit so
einer zuckermasse und lass es einfach
schön weiter schlagen
minute nämlich jetzt die hitze weg und
ihr könnt auch ich habe das auch gemacht
ich suche etwas höher gestellt damit
einfach am rand bis 1 nicht anfängt zu
gerinnen bis die ganze hitze reduzieren
fast uns zu gewinnen
jetzt können sie hier für weg ich habe
zwölf minuten 80 grad erhitzt wird es
auch der moment wenn er das ganze über
dem wasserbad macht dass sie da einfach
ein tophit herunternehmen und jetzt die
creme kalt auf schlag
210 mit der geschwindigkeit hoch sitzt
sie einmal drücken wald einfach mal zu
heiß
was genau fest
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal stehen brownie hier aus der frauen
herauslösen
den schneidet jetzt gleich in ein
fenster große würfel und kann auch hier
bereits schon mal ein bisschen wie
schokolade durchgehend die eier creme
ist schön abgekühlt die stelle ich kurz
zur seite und kann schon mal die sahne
steif schlagen
wir zeitig das café alles zusammenrühren
hier habe ich jetzt die eier masse da
kommt jetzt die geschmolzene schokolade
mit rein
jede ich jetzt vorsichtig unter als
nächstes kommt jetzt die salome trend
und zuletzt kommen jetzt noch die
brownie würfel mit rein und da habe ich
ein paar auch für die dekoration später
und die habe ich jetzt auch vorsichtig
runter und falls sie jetzt noch ein
bisschen folk mit drin haben möchte was
sich geschmacklich sehr gut finde
dann können die jetzt getrocknete
cranberries nehmen oder kirschen oder
andere früchte und die auch noch mit
unterheben
jetzt nehmt ihr eine beliebige form zum
einfüllen ich nur eine kasten kuchenform
die finde ich immer ganz hübsch wenn ich
nämlich später das café stürze dann
gehts ja so ein bisschen spitzer so wie
ich finde ich form einfach sehr schön
und damit erst später leicht rausbekommt
kleidet er die frau mit bisschen
frischhaltefolie aus
jetzt kann ich das parfait hier
vorsichtig einfüllen
da kommt es in frischhaltefolie drüber
damit einfach schön
geschützt vor dem geruch in die tiefe
wach ist und jetzt ständig ins
tiefkühlfach für mindestens sechs
stunden am besten über nacht ihr könnt
dieses café auch zwei wochen lang
aufbewahren und dann an dem tag an dem
installieren wollte einfach raus holen
wie stets kühl und dann zeige ich euch
wie man es fertig stellt uns da wird das
wahlverfahren ich hatte es mehrere tage
im gefrierfach aber wie gesagt eine
nacht reicht vollkommen aus
jetzt sei dies fertigstellen und ihr
könnt auch so bis zu zwei wochen im
gefrierfach aufbewahren hab ich hier 100
gramm zar peter kuvertüre bereits über
dem heißen wasserbad geschmolzen und
gäbe es noch 50 gramm kuvertüre dazu und
temporär sie sozusagen und damit die
quartiere nichts fest wird kommen noch
20 gramm kokosfett betreiben
das café nehme ich jetzt aus der form
heraus und stürzte auf ein abkühlen und
ab
und am besten nimmt man das auch etwa 10
bis 15 minuten vor dem servieren heraus
weil es einfach ein bisschen anschauen
kann
paris er halb gefrorenes und sollte dann
eben nicht ganz gefroren serviert werden
jetzt könnt ihr entweder das parfait in
scheiben schneiden und dann auf den
teller geben und damit der kurator
übergießen
oder was ich auch ganz schön finde vor
allem wenn man das café als ganzes
serviert dass man hier schon die
kuvertüre drüber ist zumindest einen
teil damit jetzt ein schönen anfang und
schon abschluss habe schneide ich jetzt
einen teil weg desto mehr teil der
manchmal probieren kann wo man die
qualitätskontrolle machen kann
jetzt nehme ich die kuvertüre und gss
sie ganz vorsichtig drüber ganz hübsch
aus wenn ihr einfach so streifen drüber
geht
demokrat darf jetzt gleich probieren
deswegen schneidest du jetzt hier weg
und dann setzt sich das paar erst auf
eine schöne platte also kaffee man es
hört sich als toller heimischen eis oder
ein halb gefroren ist doch ein sorbet
nehmen so wie ich nur also ich hatte
keine milch mit dabei oder sagen als ob
es halt nur frucht und wasser alles
passt kann ich schon ein paar frischen
kaffee haben
dekoriert enthält noch ein bisschen mit
kakao darf ich jetzt essen oder taxis
sind was ich auch immer ganz schön finde
wenn man so ein bisschen was braucht es
noch dazu gibt also zb so was ein
gekochtes ein paar braune stücke denn es
sind ja auch mit drin
als vorteile lägen noch eine andere
deckung okay aber ich probiere die
brownies ich glaube das würde ich ein
espresso noch grüner super das passt gut
ich mache alles probieren
mit zu freuen
also ich probier's mal mit cranberry
profis mit cranberry sind immer schön
dass schokolade gesagt etwas lustiges
und dann noch eine frucht rosina doch
ganz anders
also macht es mit den cranberries wir
sind richtig saftig cranberries also
espresso wünscht
und wie gesagt man kann es als super
kunden vorbereiten und ihr könnt ja auch
was anderes mit rein geben außer chris
brown ist wobei ich diese kommunikation
schon ziemlich gut finden gigantisch und
auch dieses lustige lustige dieses
früchte gibt dann die schokolade dazu
macht so schön und wir können ja
richtung weihnachten vielleicht noch mal
ein richtig leckeres kaffee machen sind
weihnachtlich winterliche und dann noch
dieser beiliegende unsere so weil dann
finde ich kann man so richtig angeben
boa bestechlichkeit tolles und dass er
am schluss
ich will auch mal ein bisschen kaffee
machen wir es auch möglich das kann
gerade so richtig so ein espresso fans
dann genießt du das noch ich packte sie
auf den teller machen so schnell meine
fotos und als er dieses rezept nach
machen wollt dann geht auf sallys -
blog.de da steht noch mal ganz genau für
euch und gerne dürft euch auch eine
bavaria führen wünschen was könnte ich
zu behalten was euch also ich find die
kommen jetzt schon richtig gut aber es
gibt bestimmt noch etwas was das noch
toppen kann also viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich freue mich schon auf eure
ideen und wir sehen uns schon nächsten
mal wird es wahnsinnig schnell auf den
cranberries